mr. and mrs. Ramsey are you mates good a
couple of terrible backseat drivers
[Music]
thank you very much well Murray grabs a
surprise guest Jack and I I'm there
prepared some very special meal see you
guys the kitchen Jack and I are gonna go
get the first course out wait fingers
crossed that's gonna love the food this
is our amazing ravioli actually it looks
beautiful so nice and thin let's go main
course quite emotional I might cry well
that's getting all slushy maybe that's
what happens when you get old this is
our Wow really why because you're you
Wow when I sit on the outside and pink
in the middle the perfect way to eat
fill a delicious thirsty perfect
yeah I'm incorrect types of special
desserts hon thank you very much
deserts the dish you eat last and really
remember so it's got to be super wowie
hey guys I'm not the mint-infused twice
Wow
my Wow
chili is delicious thank you so much
I wonder what he'll think of his last
surprise oh my god dad didn't time cut
it for you
what Bowl were you at the time
[Music]
[Applause]